اخفق البرلمان اللبناني للمره الثانيه
عشره في انتخاب رئيس للبلاد بعد تعثر حصول
اي من مرشحي الرئاسه جهاد ازعور وسليمان
الفرنجيه على الاصوات المطلوبه للفوز وقد
قال رئيس البرلمان ببري في بيان عقب جلسه
التصويت ان انتخاب رئيس جديد لن يتحقق الا
بما سماه التوافق وسلوك طريق الحوار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كندا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما هي التغييرات التي طرات
على خريطه التحالفات السياسيه في لبنان
على ضوء ما افرزته جلسه البرلمان الثانيه
عشره للانتخاب رئيس جديد للبلاد وما هي
ابعاد استمرار ازمه شعور الرئاسه في لبنان
وكيف تلقي بغلالها على المشهد اللبناني
على المستويات السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والامنيه والاجتماعيه
وما هي افاق وفرص التوصل الى توافق على
انتخاب رئيس جديد في جلسه البرلمان
المقبله وما الدور الذي يمكن ان تلعبه قوى
خارجيه في الوصول الى هذا التواصل
[موسيقى]
فيما يبدو او بدا وكانه مرحله جديده
يدخلها سباق الرئاسه في لبنان ببروز
مرشحين هما سليمان فرنجيه وجهاد الزهور
لاول مره في الجلسه البرلمانيه الثانيه
عشره لاختيار رئيس للبنان اخفق البرلمان
اللبناني من جديد في انتخاب رئيس للبلاد
وذلك بعد تعذر حصول اي من المرشحين على 86
صوتا من بين
128 هي مجمل اصوات البرلمان فبينما حصل
ازعور الذي تؤيده اغلبيه الكتل المسيحيه
على 59 صوتا حصد افرنجيه المدعوم من كتلتي
حزب الله وحركه امل واحدا وخمسين صوتا في
جوله التصويت الاولى بينما الغيت الجوله
الثانيه لعدم اكتمال النصاب بعد انسحاب
نواب على راسهم نواب حزب الله وحركه امل
وعاقب الجلسه اكد رئيس البرلمان ان انتخاب
رئيسا لن يتحقق الا بالتوافق وبسلوكي طريق
الحوار
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من بيروت
كل من حسين ايوب الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
وايضا جورج عقوري الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
وينضم الينا ايضا من بيروت طارق عبود
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اللبناني اهلا بكم
جميعا الى هذه الحلقه وابدا معك استاذ
حسين ايوب كيف بدت لك يعني خارطه
التحالفات السياسيه في لبنان على ضوء
نتائج جلسه مجلس النواب لاختيار الرئيس
للبلاد
مساء الخير
كما كان معروفا قبيلا عقاد الجلسه الثانيه
عشره
كانت هناك لنقل انها كانت معركه الصفرين
كان المعسكر الداعم لرئيس تيار سليمان
فرنجيه يسعى الى رقم يتجاوز الخمسين صوتا
وكانت معركه الفريق الداعم لجهاد ازعور
تجاوز رقم الستين واذا كان هناك امكانيه
ان يصل الى رقم ال65 اي النصف زائد واحد
مفاجاه الجلسه اليوم هي
كيف استطاع المعسكر الداعم الفرنجيه من
تجاوز رقم الخمسين الى 51 وبالتالي حسب
تقديرات هذا الفريق هناك اربعه اصوات
اضافيه عما كان مقدرا له ان ياخذ سليمان
فرنجيه اي 47 وهو الذي غادر القاعه عندما
انتهت الدوره الاولى يعني عندما سال رئيس
مجلس النواب ما هو عدد النواب الحاضرين
قيل له 81 يعني عمليا كان غادر حوالي 47
نائبا المفاجاه هي بتجاوز الرقم الذي كان
مقدرا بالمقابل فان الارقام التي اعطيت
لجهات ازور بانه سيتجاوز ال 60 وسيصل الى
ال65 تبين ان هناك معطيات دخلت على خط
المعسكر الداعم بجهات واعتقد
اول المعطيات هي عدم بروز عناصر خارجيه
ضاغطه وتحديدا سعوديه بدليل ان كتله
الاعتدال التي تضم عددا من نواب التيار
المستقبل لم تصوت لجهاد ازعور ولا
الاسلاميه الفرنجيه اعطت ثمان اصوات
للبنان الجديد لمرشح سمته لبنان الجديد
كما ان الفريق برغم كل الضغوطات التي تعرض
لها فريق التغيرين وانا لا اقول ذلك انا
هم نواب التغيير قالوا ان الثلاثه الذين
خرجوا عن اسم جهاد ازعور تعرضوا لضغوطات
طوال الساعات الماضيه من اجل اعطاء
اصواتهم لجهاد ازعور ولكنهم لم
يتنازلوا ويتمسكوا بمرشحين
في هذه النقطه دعنا نسال جورج عن ما اصبح
يسمى ربما بتقاطع الضروره وهو الوصف الذي
اطلقه كثير من المراقبين على توافق الكتل
المؤيده
لترشح او ترشيح ازعور او ربما لمواجهه
ترشيح الفرنجيه ما مدى قدره فعلا هذا
التقاطع ان صح التعبير على الصمود برايك
اختبط اوقاتك
ان هذا التقاطع قائم بشكل اساسي على
نقطتين اولها بطبيعه الحال عدم السماح
لوصول مرشح الثنائي الى قصر بعبده وهذه
نقطه رئيسيه خصوصا ان هذا التقاطع يقوم
بشكل اساسي وفق المكونات اللبنانيه على
اكبر حجم تمثيل مسيحي كان عبر كتله القوات
اللبنانيه او كتله التيار الحر او كتله
حزب حزب الكتائب وهذا امر اساسي من
الصعوبه طالما هذا الثلاثي على موقفه من
عدم السير بفرنجيه من الصعوبه بمكان تخطيه
عمليا والسير
افرنجيه هذا امر رئيسي من هنا اتصور ان ما
جرى في مجره اليوم هو خطوه متقدمه لناحيه
هدفين اول هدف هو الدفع الى اجراء جلسه
بعد نحو خمس او سته اشهر من
يعني الضغط باتجاه الرئيس بري الذي دعا
الى جلسه رغم انه اعلان الاتفاق
اني اني اني جلسه اليوم اني جلسه اليوم
لانه فور اعلان ازعور كان مواقف النائب
محمد رعد وحركه عمل ان هذا
مرشح مناوره وانه غير جدي الا انهم اضطروا
الى عقد جلسه هذا امر ايجابي الذهاب الى
لعبه الاصوات ايضا خطوه الى الامام خطوه
ايجابيه اتوقع ان الضغط سوف يستمر من اجل
تكرار هذا المشهديه ولكن بشكل فعال اكثر
لانه سؤال الاساسي
مساله التعطيل اليوم لو استمرينا ودعينا
الى جلسه اخرى واصبح النظام هو 65 صوت
الايصال رئيس كل الامور تكون مفتوحه ويمكن
ان نشهد خلط اوراق كما شاهدنا اليوم خلط
وتعسكر في توزيع الاصوات
في مدعونا نسال طارق عبود
فرنجيه طبعا في الحصول على غطاء مسيحي الى
اي مدى هذا يحرج ربما وانا نتحدث عن
التعسكرات كما كما
وصفهاوري الى اي حد يمكن فعلا ان يحرج هذا
حزب الله وحلفائه الذين يعني بداوا وكانهم
يفرضون على المسيحيين ربما خيالا لا
يريدونه
تحياتي لك يا استاذه خديجه وضيفيك
الكريمين اولا هذا استحقاق يعني وطني وليس
استحقاقا مسيحيا رغم كل الحديث عن يعني
الحديث الطائفي حقيقه في السياسه وفي
الزواريب السياسيه اللبنانيه لان العنوان
هو عنوان وطني يعني ماذا يقدم المرشح من
مشروع سياسي من مشروع اقتصادي قبل ان نتفق
ان هذا مرشح للمسيحيين او مرشح للمسلمين
مع انه يعني فشل اليوم يعني مجموعه تجميع
الاصوات
للدفع بجهاد ازعور ويعني الكتل المسيحيه
لكي تخاط المعركه معركه كسر العظم لازاحه
مرشح يعني حزب الله وحركه امل وبعض
الحلفاء سليمان افرنجيه لذلك اليوم يعني
لا نستطيع ان نقول ان على المرشح ان يكون
يعني مدعوما بشكل كبير من الكتله التي
ينتمي اليها هذا المرشح هناك استحقاق وطني
وانا اعتقد اليوم ان هذه الكتل المسيحيه
التي تجمعت لازاحه سليمان فرنجيه فشلت
ايضا في ايصال المرشح مرشح تقاطع وتقاطع
تجميع الاصوات لان ليس هناك مشروع واضح
لكتله القوات اللبنانيه وللتيار البطن
الحر ولحزب الكتائب ولبعض المجموعات
المتفرقه هم تجمعوا في هذه الجلسه لكي
يقولوا انهم لا يريدون سليمان افرنجيه
تجمع ولخصومه فريجيه فقط لذلك اليوم انا
اعتقد باننا علينا ان ننتقل الى خطوه اخرى
الى مرحله اخرى مرحله التوافق ومرحله
الحوار لان جلسه اليوم ورغم كل الصراخ
ورغم كل التهديد ورغم كل الاعمال التي
عقدها يعني عقدت هذه المجموعه التي صوتت
لزعور لم تصل الى 65 صوتا وهذا يعد فشلا
استراتيجيا لدفع في الدفع باذعور لرئاسه
الجمهوريه وبين مزدوجين هم يعرفون ويدركون
ولا يريدون ان يكون جهاد ازعور هو الساكن
في قصر بعبده الرئاسي لذلك سينتقلون الى
حرق اسم اخر كما حرقوا ميشال معوض واليوم
جهاد ازعور وسننتقرون الى اسم جديد لا
يعني يعني لبنانيون لا يعرفون جهات
الماليه يعني اين هو مشروع
حقا هذه الفكره طارق عبود الى حسين ايوب
يعني فعلا يعني يجب التسريع كما يقول
بالذهاب الى الخطوه المقبله ولا يمكن ان
نستمر هكذا في حرق الاسماء اسما وراء اسم
خصوصا انه الازمه الاقتصاديه والازمه
الاجتماعيه تاكل
وتحرق لبنان هناك استحقاق كما هو معروف
قادم وتعيين حاكم لمصرف لبنان الذي سيشغل
منصبه في اعتبارا من شهر يوليو هل كل هذا
ربما
لنقل يعني يعزز فكره الدفع باتجاه التسريع
للخطوه القادمه
للاسف سيدتي الكريمه لا اعتقد ذلك ابدا
نحن امام واقع انسداد سياسي كبير في لبنان
الارقام اليوم تشهي بالقول انه الاكلات
طرفين يملك الثلث المعطل الكفيل بعدم
توفير النصاب للدوره الثانيه وبالتالي
مشهد الجلسه الثانيه عشره يمكن ان يتكرر
10 مرات كما تكررت صيغه الورقه البيضاء مع
ميشال المعوض
من يستطيع كسر هذا الساتيكو الداخلي من
الانسداد غير متوفر لا اذا دعا رئيس مجلس
النواب للحوار هناك من يلبي الدعوه ولا
اذا بتركي دعت القاده المسيحيين سيلبون
الدعوه جرت محاوله في الاتجاهين وفشلت
يصبح السؤال هل هناك من الادوات الخارجيه
ما هو قادر على كسر الانسداد السياسي
الداخلي ام ان الخارج الان لا يريد ان
يكون لبنان اولويه
اعتقد اننا امام مرحله انسداد سياسي في
الداخل
نعم ما الذي يجعلك تقول لان لبنان ليس
اولويه بالنسبه للخارج وفرنسا هيا
مبعوثا وايضا سيكون ملف لبنان مطروحا ايضا
في السعوديه
يعني بين عفوا بين ولي العهد السعودي
والرئيس الفرنسي في باريس اليس في ذلك ما
يدل فيما يدل على الاهتمام الدولي بالملف
اللبناني
رئيس فرنسا زارا لبنان مرتين بعد انفجار
مرفا بيروت في العام
2021 يعني منذ سنتين وجرت محاوله لجمع
القاده اللبنانيين مرتين في قصر الصنوبر
في بيروت وجرت محاولات عديده من خلال
مفادين وكما هو معروف الوساطه الفرنسيه ثم
من خلال مجموعه الخماسيه برغم كل كل ما
شهدناه منذ 17 تشرين حتى اليوم يعني منذ
اكثر من ثلاث سنوات ما زال الانسداد
السياسي القائم نحن على عتبه الشهر السابع
من الفراغ الرئاسي كنا نقول ان الوضع في
لبنان لا يحتمل فراغا لمده اشهر وان هذا
الفراغ يجب ان يملا قبل موعد
انتهاء ولايه حاكم مصرف لبنان المركزي
اعتقد ان ولايه حاكم مصرف لبنان المركزي
ستنتهي وسيحل محله نائبه وسيم منصوري ولا
ارى في الافق القريب رئيسا للجمهوريه حتما
الاولويات المطروحه بين الفرنسيين
والسعودي في القمه المنوي عقدها اكبر
بكثير من الملف اللبناني
اعتقد
الامر الذي يجب ان نعول عليه هو
تقاطع
دولي مع واقع محلي لانها لناخذ مثلا سيدتي
الان اتفق العالم كله على اكس رئيسا
للجمهوريه وقال الثلاثي المسيحي التيار
الوطني الحر والقوات اللبنانيه وحزب
الكتائب لا نريد فلان رئيسا للجمهوريه كما
حصل في العام 1988 عندما اتفق الرئيس
الاسد مع ميرفي على مخيل الظاهر وسقط خيار
مخيل الظاهر عندما اتفق الموارنه على عدم
تمرير الان اذا اتفق العالم كله هذه القوى
ثلاثه تملك ثلثا معطلا يعني 21 زائد 19
يساوي 40 زائد اربع نواب للكتائب 44 هم
يحتاجون الى 43 نائبا الثلث المعطل
المساله معقده وليست سهله نحن بحاجه ولكن
مع هذا الانقسام الشديد وهنا اعود الى
جورج مع هذا الانقسام الشديد للبرلمان
لمجلس النواب اللبناني
تبدو فكره التدخل الاجنبي ربما ضروريه لحل
هذه الازمه وهذا ما اثبته تاريخ لبنان
دائما ازمات لبنان كانت تحل بي تدخلات
خارجيه الان مع افاده المبعوث الفرنسي جاي
الاسبوع المقبل الى لبنان وهذا الحرك ربما
الاقليمي والدولي هل يبشر ربما بذلك
دعني اقول ان الاستحقاق للرئاس اللبنانيه
يستطيع ان يتاثر بالضغط الخارجي من 5% الى
95%
فلا زال بالامكان كما قال زميلي ان يكون
هناك تعطيل داخلي
لذا الاهميه
بافاد الوزير الخارجيه السابق الى لبنان
هي اهميه ترتبط باعاده النظر
بدور الخارجيه بدور الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه
لان هذه النقطه تعتبر نقطه
اصابت معسكر معسكر الثنائي
بسهم لان التغطيه الفرنسيه لفرنجيه قد
سحبت واصبحت فرنسا اليوم تلعب
كدافع نحو تامين ايصال رئيس الجمهوريه
وانسحبت من زواريب السياسه ومن الدعم
المباشر الذي كان يقوم به الرئيس الفرنسي
لفرنجيه فهذا نقطه ضعف الفرنجيه هذا اولا
ثانيا ان اردنا ان نتحدث عن الضغوط
الدوليه نعم اثبت المملكه اليوم انها لا
تتدخل بالمباشر في لبنان وكان هناك هناك
حريه خيار للتصويت خصوصا من قبل
التكتل الاعتدال النقطه الثالثه سمانه
تغريده للسفير الايراني الذي
دعا عقب الجلسه الى ان على اللبنانيين ان
يتفقوا ان يتفقوا ان يذهبوا الى مرشح
توافقي وهذا امر ايضا مستغرب لان الحياه
الديمقراطيه والحياه الانتخابيه في كافه
الدول العالم تقوم على التنافس داخل
صناديق الاقتراع المطلوب اليوم ان يكون
هناك هذا التفاعل الداخلي من اجل الوصول
الى مساحه مشتركه ما شاهدناها اليوم هو
تعنت الثنائي بمرشحه لقد اثبتت المعارضه
ان استطاعت ان تخطو خطوه الى الامام من
اجل مصلحه لبنان والحدنا الفراغ تخلت عن
مرشحا اساسيه لديها هو المرشح
مرشح معوض
وطرحت مبادره
مهمه عبر الذهاب الى مرشح غير استفزازي هو
الوزير جاد ازعور والذي للاشاره
بما يتعلق بالمراب بالبرامج بطبيعه الحال
يملك برنامج اقتصادي اساسي وبما يتعلق
بالشان السياسي هناك خطوط عريضه له من هنا
يمكن القول انها المعارضه قامت بخطوه الى
الوسط انما المشكله ان الفريق الاخر اي
الثنائي
يتمطرس خلف مرشحه الذي سماه بالامس النائب
محمد رعد مرشح المقاومه ويريدنا جميع ان
يمشي في ركوبه وان يوصل مرشحه وهذا امر
غير منطقي من يريد مصلحه لبنان عليه ان
يسير الى
مشتركه وان يتوقف عن هذه العنجه هي التي
تحدث عنها بالامس الوزير جبران باسيل طيب
مع كل هذه
الادوار التي يمكن ان نزلها نتحدث عن
الدور الخارجي والشارجورج الان الى تغريده
لمسؤول ايراني
ترقبوج
الى جانب ذلك هناك انفتاح عربي على طبعا
على سوريا وتفاهم السعوديه ايرانيه على في
موضوع تيسير توافق الفرقاء اللبنانيين على
رئيس جديد كيف تنظرون انتم الى ذلك
حقيقه استاذه خديجه خلينا نكون واضحين
هناك
انتظار
للتسويه الاقليميه انا هذا رايي
ودائما ما كان استحقاق رئاسه الجمهوريه
واستحقاق تؤدي فيه الدول او الادوار
الخارجيه يعني دورا كبيرا على المستوى
السياسي لم يتفق اللبنانيون في تاريخهم
الحديث منذ 43 على رئيس يعني من ضمن
البوانتاج الذي كان
يتشكل منه المجلس النيابي واليوم نحن بعد
انتخابات 2020 وهذا التعقيد في المشهد
السياسي والتوزع القوى اليوم ايضا ينتظر
اللبنانيون هذه التسويه الخارجيه لان
اللبنانيين بعض 2005 كمان لكي نكون واضحين
لم يستطيعوا ان يديروا شؤونهم الداخليه من
دون تدخل اقليمي ومن دون وصايه خارجيه منذ
الانتداب الى
2005 اليوم لبنان انا اعتقد بانه في اسفل
الاهتمامات الدوليه والاقليميه الخاصه
الاقليميه هناك لماذا في اسفل اهتمامات
الدوليه والان في الاخبار العاجله هناك
عاجل من الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول ان
واشنطن منزعجه لمغادره اعضاء بالبرلمان
اللبناني القاعه لمنع التصويت على انتخاب
الرئيس في ذلك اهتمام امريكي كما هناك
اهتمام فرنسي وهناك اهتمام سعودي واهتمام
ايراني بهذه الانتخابات ما تعليقك على ما
جاء على لسان الخارجي الامريكيه يعني لم
نرصد لم نرصد لم نرصد حركه خارجيه حركه
امريكيه في الى لبنان وحتى بعد وصول
الرئيس الديمقراطي جوبيدا يعني اختلفت
الحركه الامريكيه اتجاه لبنان الحركه
الفرنسيه هي حركه بلا بركه كما يقول المثل
اللبناني الاتفاق الايراني الى اليوم لم
ينعكس على الواقع السياسي اللبناني اكثر
المتفائلين كانوا يقولون بان الاتفاق بين
ايران وبين سوريا واعاده بين ايران
والسعوديه واعاده العلاقات بين هاتين
الدولتين الاقليميتين الكبيرهتين سيؤثر
ايجابا وبسرعه على الواقع السياسي
اللبناني وسينتخب اللبنانيون رئيسا جديدا
اليوم هناك ملفات يعني يهتم بها السعوديون
والايرانيون هم الملف اليمني اولا الملف
السوري ثانيا والملف العراقي ثالثا واخيرا
الملف اللبناني لذلك اليوم في اسفل قائمه
الاهتمامات شكرا جزيلا لك طارق عبود
الكاتب والمحلل السياسيه اللبناني وشكرا
لجورجاكوري ايضا الكاتب المحلي السياسي
اللبناني واشكر ايضا حسين ايوب ايضا
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اللبناني كنتم
معنا جميعا من بيروت وبهذا ناتي الى ختام
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر لكم
منا اطيب المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]